it's time to wash the floofy Newfie bear
get in here
news
so this is one of the Bengal Bengal
Newfoundlands I'm trying to be like that
guy that shows the cats on the tick tock
oh he's too heavy okay you ready it's
time it's bath time you're stinky I took
you out in the rain
you were running around the field let's
go in bath time
excellent job
Bear's really easy to wash actually
because he's just like down for anything
but I like to tell him like I do with my
patients all the things I'm gonna do
before I do them so bear the first thing
I'm going to do is turn on the water
then I'm gonna wet you I'm Gonna Get You
very wet then once that happens I'm
gonna get the shampoo and I'm gonna
lather you up once you're fully lathered
I'm gonna make sure I get all ends
washed from top to bottom do you agree
high five if you agree okay you agree
good the problem with this water is
sometimes it has really bad control over
temperature so I want to make sure that
it's not too hot because for dogs hot
water is no bueno the craziest thing
about bear is that he looks huge when
he's all poofy but when he starts
getting wet he's actually really skinny
bear how you feeling about this
his uh fur is actually a little oily the
top layer so it prevents water from
getting in they can have a kiss while I
wash you thank you
so you got to be careful when you get
dog shampoo like I did I got the one
that's concentrated so you're gonna need
to dilute it pretty heavily okay this is
your shampoo
[Music]
this is the version of a dog sponge so
you want to introduce it to the dog so
he he feels safe with it lets him smell
it I mean Bears really laid back so it
doesn't matter at all what you're doing
but okay now we watch the new make sure
we get deep into his skin folds the good
part about this rubbery thing is it does
a good job of getting through the fur
even nuts
also when you do this with your dog it
should be a fun thing so like bring your
dog snacks is great where do you want to
snack or do you want to just lick my
face your breath's gonna smell better
after I brush your teeth though look how
much fur comes out of this guy
[Music]
oh okay I feel like you're concentrating
on solving on that problem which math
problem are you thinking about clean the
butt he doesn't like that go boy bear
good boy oh my God look at this
I have a special like shamwow-esque
product here where you can actually put
your hands inside of this it just hugs
your dog like it's a giant little loofah
giant a little loofah look at that he's
being born and I want to do this as much
as possible before he starts flicking it
off all over the place yeah
okay he did it nonetheless wow this is
soaked already
then I have the next sham wow dog towel
these are super absorbent so they do a
great job at holding the water and
pulling the water off the dog okay come
on
you see the floors already soaked that
he just came out May are you happy
hang out here for a second tell me this
doesn't look like the Twin Turbo back
end of a jet you might look at this
contraption and say to yourself why in
the world do you need such a crazy dog
blower dog skin is too sensitive so you
can't really use heat the goal with dogs
and drying them especially big floofy
dogs like bear is to blow the wetness
off of them
thank you
when you blow really forceful air you
could actually see his skin and that
allows me as I go through to see if
there's any rashes or anything else
popping up in the skin also a mistake
that a lot of people make with these if
you go in like circles like this you
could actually create tangles in your
dog's hair so the goal is to always do
it in One Direction
[Music]
oh my low back oh the tail stays Waggy
right right
yeah this is like a shearing blade it's
a comb but on the other end it's really
sharp so when you're going through his
floof it could actually take extra hair
out and tangles out a lot of dog
groomers will avoid using these because
some people overuse them and start like
ripping hair out of their dog so you
have to be really conscientious about
how you use this
it'd be fun they said when hair clumps
together on a dog like this oxygen and
air stops being able to pass through it
the dog becomes more vulnerable to skin
infections fungal and bacteria I had a
groomer for for about a year and then
they just started jacking up their
prices to like 600 even though this
takes only two hours
I mean they do come to you but then
their scheduling system was a mess and I
actually enjoyed doing this the only
negative part about this is obviously
the hair everywhere so you have to
vacuum after and then also the fact that
uh my water pressure sucks but otherwise
it's great
it's very therapeutic it's probably why
like moms or dads play with like braid
their children's hair it's like it's fun
for them and you also see that in other
primates I think monkeys love grooming
each other too
like I'm a monkey right now grooming a
bear interspecies grooming
do you think he likes it though look
this guy
drooling
this is a wire brush
it's like good for finishing his coat
but I also use it in between to sort of
get some of the smaller tangles out
before I go with the bigger brush didn't
he get bigger
it's because he gets flu here
[Music]
crazy again whatever thing you use on
your dog introduce it to the dog bear
hasn't seen us in a little while because
I wasn't cooking him so I need him to be
calm but I turn this on turn it on let
him see that nothing bad happens and
then basically I just want to clean up
the fur in between his paws here because
when it overgrows it can be a problem
[Applause]
I'm actually surprised Bear's so
comfortable with letting me play with
his paws because when he was a puppy he
actually cut his paw real bad and I had
to take Staples out of it after he got
an operation and he let me do it like a
champ but it's important when your dog's
a puppy that you handle their paws
regularly for this exact reason so that
you can groom your dog here we have a
Dremel which is how I shorten Bear's
nails if you actually apply a slight
pressure to the top of the nail into the
bottom of the paw pad like this you can
express the nail a little bit further
which will allow you to visualize the
vein better
[Music]
foreign
to take care of your gums and teeth to
make sure that you don't get cavities
there is a little annoying when brushing
teeth because he likes to eat the
toothbrush okay so we can get some of
the toothpaste
on the toothbrush and bear will give you
his teeth
and allow you to brush them
and he'll eat the toothpaste like I said
this is not a glamorous job but it's a
job that someone has to do the hardest
part is getting the back teeth yeah I'm
getting those back teeth don't chew the
toothbrush just wait wait before you
chew the toothbrush please I actually
don't mind when he chews so much on the
back ones because then it's like he's
helping me brush
next we need to clean the inside of well
not really the inside more like the
outer inside of Bear's ear and I have
these special wipes that my vet
recommended they're called vets vest
they have witch hazel aloe vera and tea
tree oil all good ingredients against
infections the goal is not to go inside
your dog's ear fully but just to
visualize the ear and get the gunk out
bear gets a lot of gunk in his ears
again because of his floopiness of his
ears see how gross it is already I also
sometimes will use a solution if there's
like a lot of earwax or a lot of build
up that you actually put into his ear
and then let him shake his ear out oh
and a lot of people don't let their dog
shake their heads when they're cleaning
their ears definitely let them because
that could mean some water got in there
and the way that they get it out is by
shaking last part of Bear's grooming
routine is to get them outside of the
bathroom away from all this hair before
we move on to the next section status
check-in of the Barefoot hair
all right part two we want to get him
out of the bathroom because it's really
wet in there and hairy so we want to do
the finishing touches in here he's
already coming to join us all right new
we're gonna finish her coat now and blow
you out then I'm gonna do a little
haircut for you because you're getting a
little bit too poofy high five if that's
okay okay good
play dead
[Music]
not the most glamorous part of owning a
dog shaving his face but he gets a lot
of rashes here because of the moisture
gets trapped
[Music]
is this incredible dad
well how would bear survive in the wild
that's my question he would get so
matted so quickly on his first day of
being wet he would get skin infections
Galore
I think this is already more further
than we had in the bathroom yeah
I know
the least glamorous part of having a dog
here he's looking back at me as I do it
yeah clean my foot
gotta keep the back area hygienic
right new look at the shine on this coat
this is a healthy mammal right here how
do you feel
you smell nice
mmm who's happy who's happy click give
me a hug
yeah you're happy
I think a breath smells nice all right
the floof is clean he's dry for the most
part he's happy look at how much fur
leaves this animal and honestly if I sat
here brushing him for another hour
probably I could double this but as you
can tell it's pretty easy to groom a dog
that behaves well so it's important to
handle your dog early get them used to
you being the owner and playing with
them and cleaning their ears and their
teeth and their paws because then it
becomes a rewarding experience for the
both of you that's why Bear's a happy
pot right yeah a good one check out
Bear's video when I first got him click
here to check that out and as always
stay happy and healthy